Hallo, guten Abend.
Wir denken, ihr habt alle ein bisschen Vorfreude mitgebracht. Wolfgang vielleicht auch. Freust du dich auf das Oktoberfest?
Nein, denn ich trinke kein Bier, versuche München zu meiden, bin froh heute in Frankfurt zu sein. Hab mich aber heute auf der Fahrt hierhin kundig gemacht, wie es bei Heidi Klungs Oktoberfest war. Und ja, die Wildecker Herzbuben sind aufgetreten und auf noch The Weather Girls.
Alle gibt es noch.
Ja, alle gibt es noch. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie alle vier zusammen auf einer Bühne waren.
Okay, dann feiern wir heute auch ein Fest des Lebens mit unserem Intro.
Wir können uns natürlich auch fragen, haben wir heute ein Reenactment vor? Wollen wir vielleicht einfach nochmal den Live-Sonnen vom vergangenen Jahr machen?
Wem ist es aufgefallen? September 24. Wer wünscht sich zurück in den September 24, als alles noch besser war? Unser Finanzminister Christian Lindner sagte, hast doch gerade nur eine Krise, das geht doch vorbei.
Ja, schön waren die Zeiten. Wie war es jetzt bei dir? Du hast dir ja gedacht, ich setze die 24 ins Cover, um an alte Zeiten zu erinnern, oder war es einfach schon die KI, die sich im Jahr vertauscht hat?
Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich habe das Datum eingeblendet. Ich weiß gar nicht. Allerdings heißt die Datei hier auch, die hat so slash Copy. Also es ist so eine, nicht die Originale, wie auch immer. Ja, aber ihr seht den Herrn Hegemon.
Auf dem Cover ist Herr Hegemon.
Ja, noch ist es ein Rätsel.
Gut, sollen wir uns vielleicht der Frage, ob es schon eine rechte Hegemonie gibt oder so, erstmal anders widmen? Denn es gibt ja ein sehr gutes Feature gerade beim Deutschlandfunk. Vielleicht haben es manche auch schon gehört. Insgesamt über zwei Stunden. Wir hören jetzt nur fünfeinhalb Minuten daraus.